steak Oh
close close so close ma'am I mean it's
kind of the same right it's just like a
baby's marks a mistake boy shoes oh dang
it you're allergic to nuts I'm allergic
to nuts I don't know I can't even I mean
they could kill me yeah but I've never
seen you put a piece of lettuce in your
mouth ever not once I mean when 12 years
let's let us let us go from me glass of
wine and some TV oh my gosh that's
pretty close I mean that's book and some
hot tea what do you Hobbit actually I'm
wrong about my own thing and he's right
dinner out chinese has a dinner of candy
with his with his wife and his dog sign
icon
psychopath right right but it's the best
kind of psychopath like you don't have
to hang out with them all the time
right exactly kind of sorry that's the
same answer same answer that is the same
answer that's a point to the terminus to
the turn in the movie it's definitely in
the movie well right cuz he was I didn't
really hear it so much as I read he was
always doing like fart jokes I heard
exactly he was yeah he was out of his
bloody mind